bonbons bonjour à tous je m'appelle jean
baptiste de froment je suis secrétaire
national donc un enseignement supérieur
et à la recherche et après avoir
enseigné quelques années à l'université
la philosophie j'ai eu la chance de
conseiller le président sarkozy à
l'elysée pendant cinq ans sur sur les
questions d'éducation et je suis
aujourd'hui également élu conseiller de
paris élu du 9e arrondissement
alors on a déjà perdu un petit peu de
temps donc enfin on en est on à gagner
du temps mais en même temps ça nous a
pris du temps
et voila voila et est donc est donc
maintenant et donc il va falloir qu'on
soit particulièrement synthétique et je
vais essayé de m'appliquer ça à moi même
pour pour introduire cette table ronde
consacrée à l'enseignement supérieur et
à la recherche insiste sur ce couple
parce que c'est très important de ne pas
séparer enseignement supérieur et
recherche
j'aurais juste commencer par par deux
chiffres le premier chiffre ses 2700
milliards de 1700 milliards de dollars
c'est le montant total du chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises qui ont été
créées
je lis pas dire il dirige est créé par
les anciens étudiants d'une seule
université américaine qui est
l'université de standford je pourrais ce
chiffre dans le dernier rapport de
l'institut montaigne cher laurent
bigorgne et ses entreprises qui ont été
créées qui font 2700 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires
elle se trouve pour moitié d'entre elles
à proximité immédiate de cette
université et on estime qu'elle emploie
près de 6 millions de personnes
aujourd'hui premiers chiffres second
chiffre c'est 90%
ça c'est un chiffre que j'ai construit
moi même 90%
c'est la part des non diplômés et des
peu diplômés c'est à dire simplement
diplômés de l'enseignement supérieur
dans les nouveaux chômeurs créés par la
crise de 2008 en france donc
il y a eu quelque chose comme un million
de nouveaux chômeurs depuis depuis 2008
et surtout depuis 2012 et parmi ceux
millions là vous avez 90 % des gens qui
sont soit pas diplômé du tout soit
simplement diplômés du secondaire c'est
à dire qu'ils ont un ca fait un bep etc
voilà ces deux chiffres qui sont de
nature très différente
elle en fait nous donne un point de vue
sur une même réalité
et cette réalité c'est que nous sommes
entrés mais vraiment mais vraiment
concrètement dans l'économie du savoir
l'économie du savoir ça veut dire tout
simplement que va le savoir
c'est devenu aujourd'hui le nouveau
pétrole et que l'université qui est le
lieu de production de se savoir
ça devient pratiquement le centre de
l'activité économique de plus en plus je
parlais je parlais de l'université de
stanford
toute la nouvelle économie un commencer
par des grandes entreprises comme google
elles l ont été pratiquement créé par
les universités américaines comme
sanford ou berkeley on peut dire que les
les universités les centres
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
sont les lieux même où ce fonds
ce fait la croissance aujourd'hui
et voilà dans une économie où finalement
la production l'enjeu c'est de moins en
moins de fabrique et il faut fabriquer
mais c'est de plus en plus facile de
préfabriqués et l'enjeu c'est de plus en
plus de concevoir d'avoir des idées et
on a une étude aussi du cabinet roland
berger requis qui nous dit que
d'ici 2025 on aura trois millions
d'emplois traditionnelle qui seront
détruits en france du fait de la
robotisation et de la digitalisation et
donc cesser millions d'emplois il faut
les remplacer par des nouveaux emplois
et pour ça évidemment il faut avoir un
système d'enseignement supérieur et de
recherche fort
un système qui soit mise à niveau et
aujourd'hui c'est loin d'être le cas à
ce qu on a le sentiment que depuis 2012
alors qu'il y avait un effort
gigantesque qui avait été réalisé à
partir de 2008 avec la loi et creysse
d'autonomie des universités on a fait au
mieux du surplace au pire on a régressé
et maintenant il y a une véritable il ya
une véritable urgence pour remettre
notre système à niveaux avec deux enjeux
majeurs à mon sens il y en a d'autres
le premier enjeu c'est celui du
financement on a des universités qui
aujourd'hui sont trop pauvres pro
pauvres et le second enjeu c'est celui
de l'orientation
aujourd'hui on a ce qu'on appelle une
sélection par l'échec c'est à dire qu'on
a un taux d'échec à l'université qui est
absolument considérable
on a 2 % des lycéens professionnels et 7
% des lycéens technologique par des
bacheliers professionnels schalit
technologique qui réussissent leur
licence en trois ans le but c'est quand
même de réussir sa licence en trois ans
ça devrait être la norme
donc on a on a un véritable on avait un
véritable problème d'orientation qui est
majeur et alors on a un certain nombre
de propositions et que
donnera le président sarkozy tout à
l'heure dans le cadre de son discours
donc je n'en dirai pas tellement plus à
ce stade ce que je voudrais juste dire
c'est que pour relever ces défis pour
remettre notre université à niveau eh
bien on fait confiance aux universités
elles mêmes et on pense que la solution
c'est pas ne viendra pas d'en haut comme
mon ami tu as 2001 je le disais tout à
l'heure que l'immobilisme venait d'en
haut
je crois qu'il a parfaitement raison et
que donc il faut donner plus de liberté
encore aux universités il faut achever
le mouvement d'autonomie qui avait été
engagé mais depuis ça s'est un petit peu
enrayée on a plutôt assisté à une
recentralisation massive des choses et
donc voilà la clé est la porte d'entrée
c'est l'autonomie la verte la phase deux
de l'autonomie
alors pour pour nous parler tout ça on a
on a cinq intervenants de choc
je sais pas si je prends par papa par
l'ordre on peut commencer par patrick
patrick est elle donc le patrick head
zèle qui est député mais qui est
également professeur des universités qui
a été fait des fonctions éminentes a
d'abord à matignon auprès de françois
fillon qui a été directeur général de
l'enseignement supérieur et qui veut
nous parler de quelque chose d'essentiel
qui est de la mission d'insertion
professionnelle dans les universités
patrick merci beaucoup merci jean
baptiste mesdames et messieurs bonjour
l'enseignement supérieur jean baptiste
de froment vient de l'indiquer à
l'instant c'est évidemment un enjeu
majeur notamment pour nos sociétés
occidentales parce que l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche sont des
leviers importants pour nous permettre
de continuer à être des nations qui
comptent dans les années à venir et
cette bataille de la connaissance à
laquelle il faisait référence est une
bataille qui sera de plus en plus rude
parce qu'un certain nombre de pays
nouveaux apparaissent de manière
extrêmement forte d'ailleurs plus si
nouveau que cela
en l'occurrence la chine l'inde et
d'autres qui aujourd'hui exerce une
pression très forte dans ce secteur
simplement avant de devenir à la
question de l'insertion professionnelle
quelques chiffres pour pour que vous
perceviez ce qui est en train de se
passer à l'échelle à la fois de notre
pays et ce qui se passe aussi évidemment
à l'échelle mondiale il y à un demi
siècle en france dans le post bac
il y avait trois cent mille jeunes dans
les années 60 trois cent mille jeunes
dans le post bac
aujourd'hui nous en sommes en france à 2
4 millions c'est à dire qu'en fait le
nombre de jeunes dans le système post
bac a été multiplié par huit en l'espace
d'un demi siècle là où notre population
est passée de 40 millions à 60 millions
mais on voit bien que les proportions ne
sont pas les mêmes donc il y à un
phénomène de massification qui s'est
opérée ce phénomène de massification il
opère aussi à l'échelle internationale
et pour que vous ayez là aussi un ordre
d'idée il faut savoir que ça fait
maintenant dix ans que tous les ans à
l'échelle mondiale la population
étudiante est en train de croître à peu
près dans les 2 l'équivalent de notre
population étudiante française est donc
en fait ça je pense que c'est une donnée
extrêmement importante ne pouvons pas la
négliger
et elle est tellement importante que
certains pays ont très très bien compris
que l'enseignement supérieur non
seulement était un enjeu pour le
développement direct de leurs propres
populations
mais ont même su en faire un outil de
développement de leur croissance
économique
si vous regardez quel est le troisième
poste le plus contributeur au commerce
extérieur australien vous apercevrez que
ce troisième poste et l'enseignement
supérieur et dans les universités
aujourd'hui australienne vous avez 20 %
d'étudiants australien 80 % d'étudiants
étrangers et se sont très largement les
étudiants étrangers qui contribue à
financer les études des étudiants
australiens
vous aurez compris qu'en france nous
sommes encore très très loin de ce
système là évidemment il ne s'agit pas
la france ça n'est pas l'australie par
contre il ya un certain nombre de choses
où il va falloir évoluer et le deuxième
point sur lequel effectivement je
voudrais insister c'est aujourd'hui
l'enjeu de l'insertion professionnelle
c'est un enjeu qui a largement été
perçus au cours de la législature 2007
là aussi jean baptiste le rappelait la
loi libertés et responsabilités des
universités qui a été porté par valérie
pécresse est une loi qui justement a été
la première à inscrire parmi les
missions de l'enseignement supérieur la
question de l'insertion professionnelle
parce qu'effectivement lorsque vous avez
trois cent mille jeunes dans les années
60 et que ces jeunes évidemment sont
dans une situation on est dans une
économie de croissance est bien la
question de l'emploi ne se pose pas
quand vous avez 2,4 millions de jeunes
qui se trouvent aujourd'hui dans le post
bac et que nous avons par ailleurs des
difficultés économiques et bien la
question de l'insertion professionnelle
et elle se pose avec une acuité beaucoup
plus important et donc permet quand même
aussi de dire que si l'on veut aller
jusqu'au bout de cette logique de
l'insertion professionnelle
ça a été inscrit dans la loi ça ça aussi
été un sujet qui a été très largement
repris par les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur mais il faut
bien dire que 2012 et c'est très clair a
été un couperet parce qu'en 2012 on a
décidé de stopper cet élan on est en
train de recentraliser là où on avait
très largement déconcentrées et
décentralisées fait en sorte que les
décisions se prennent le plus près
possible du terrain eh bien on a là
aussi rogné sur ses libertés donnée aux
établissements et surtout on a supprimé
un certain nombre de choses qui avait
été mise en place par exemple on avait
commencé à mettre en place durant cette
période le fait que la dotation des
universités comportait deux volets un
volet à l'activité c'est à dire que vous
avez tant d'étudiants vous avez été le
type d'activité ces étudiants sont dans
tel type de cursus
voilà ce que vous avez comme dotation et
puis il y avait un petit veau
mais qui était prévu là aussi cette fois
ci sur des atteintes d'objectifs c'est à
dire on était plus à l'activité mais on
était à la performance est bien là aussi
évidemment ça a été supprimée parce que
évidemment cette cette logique là
évidemment semblait être contraire à ce
que souhaitait mettre en place le
gouvernement à partir de 2012 et en
faisant cela et bien on a coupé les
ailes à ce développement autour de
l'insertion professionnelle et je pense
que c'est évidemment nous aurons un
certain nombre de choses à faire si nous
avons la chance de dettes aux affaires à
partir de 2017
il faut évidemment passer à une phase
deux de l'autonomie m cette fois ci en
place une démultipliés pour faire en
sorte que et bien des établissements qui
sont volontaires on puisse les
accompagner dans des expérimentations
notre système a besoin de respiration a
besoin d'innovation
mais surtout ce dont il a besoin aussi
c'est que l'on fasse en sorte que et
bien les conditions soient réunies pour
que il se rapproche encore davantage de
du marché de l'emploi
nous avons aujourd'hui un système où en
réalité on le voit madame vallaud
belkacem
face à la difficulté que rencontrent les
universités puisqu'en fait un avis du
conseil d'état précise qu' il n'y a pas
de décret qui permet de sélectionner
entre le la première et la deuxième
année du master au lieu de dire je prend
le problème à bras le corps et
d'ailleurs je mets en place maintenant
le lmd c'est à dire je crée une
sélection à l'entrée du master eh bien
non elle l a même fait des déclarations
que personne n'a compris à l'assemblée
nationale des déclarations où elle dit
est bien la sélection et il faut il faut
absolument l'éliminer mais elle ne sera
envisagée que de manière extrêmement
restrictives enfin quand on fait ça en
réalité on sélectionne par l'échec c'est
à dire que en fait on fait comme s'il
n'y avait pas de problème est en réalité
en fait c'est un miroir aux alouettes
c'est un leurre et les premiers que l'on
est en train de le ré ce sont les
étudiants eux mêmes ont leur les
familles évidemment on leur l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens
en imaginant que on peut là aussi
regret c'est dans le système sans
sélection donc je pense qu'il ya un vrai
travail à faire pour que nous ayons des
sorties qualifiante
après la licence ce travail avait été
engagé d'ailleurs sous valérie pécresse
et ensuite laurent wauquiez a également
fortement développer la
professionnalisation de la licence et ce
processus en fait a été je dirais stoppé
à partir de 2012 donc il faudra le
réengager et faire en sorte que et bien
cette question de la relation avec les
milieux professionnels non seulement ne
soit pas anecdotique mais soit
véritablement l'un des coeurs du
réacteur et ça ça ne peut effectivement
pas se décider au niveau central
nous devons mettre en place des
conditions qui permettent aux
établissements de développer des
initiatives faire en sorte que les
établissements puissent là aussi prendre
des désaccords avec les milieux
professionnels et ça ça n'est pas au
niveau central que ça doit être décidée
voilà quelques quelques idées ex abrupto
sur cette question de l'enseignement
stern
merci beaucoup patrick pour ce panorama
très complet pour compléter moscou ce
qu'on entend beaucoup quand on discute
avec les spécialistes et dames en
matière d'insertion professionnelle
c'est c'est la nécessité absolue de
développer des formations bac + 3
directement professionnalisantes c'est
vraiment un échelon du système éducatif
qui manque beaucoup beaucoup
aujourd'hui je laisse maintenant la
parole à daniel fasquelle qui est
évidemment les responsabilités qu'on
connaît au sein de notre famille
politique qui est député maire du
touquet par ailleurs mais qui est aussi
un grand universitaire et qui a été
pendant dix ans doyen d'une de la
faculté de droit de boulogne sur mer
après avoir enseigné avant à cette paris
d'assas et qui justement veut nous
parler de la phase deux de l'autonomie
avec avec un point de vue qui est ce lui
aussi d'un acteur de terrain de
l'université merci beaucoup au cra sur
et vous je vous parlerai pas d'argent
aujourd'hui mais je vous parlais de
l'université donc le diagnostic
on en connaît l'université française est
malade est profondément malade non
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une
massification non maîtrisée
l'enseignement supérieur on s'est
focalisé en permanence sur l'axé on a
voulu toujours rendre plus facile
l'accès à l'université on a complètement
oublié la question des débouchés
or le bac n'est plus un filtre est par
ailleurs les bacs pros les bagues
techniques permettent l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur alors que c'est
en france et élèves ne sont absolument
pas préparés d'enseignement supérieur ce
qui donne en fait des taux d'échec
absolument dramatique en première année
en deuxième année
le tout étant aggravée par le fait qu'on
ne parle jamais des débouchés s'agissant
des avocats par exemple je suis
professeur de droit les avocats noms
d'avocats augmenté de 50% cours des dix
dernières années
il ya aujourd'hui une paupérisation de
cette profession parce qu'on s'est
jamais posé la question à savoir si on
avait raison ou non de continuer à
former autant d'avocats il ya
aujourd'hui 500 mille étudiants inscrits
en lettres et sciences humaines
que vont-ils devenir demain mais
personne ne veut jamais se poser cette
question le système continue de
fonctionner de ronronner et de former
des étudiants sans sans débouchés et 100
et 100 métiers des réformes aussi qui
ont fait la luge mans l'allongement de
la durée des études une fin une fin en
soi qu après 80 % d'une classe d'âge au
bac tout doucement on s'oriente vers 4
en passant d'une classe d'âge à la
licence puis après ce sera 80 % d'une
classe d'âge qui doit avoir le master et
puis pourquoi pas 80 % d'une classe
d'âge qui doit voir le doctorat et comme
s'était dit avant moi
on pense qu'on est plus efficace parce
qu'on regarde plus longtemps les élèves
ou les étudiants de notre système
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait faux
il n'y a pas de lien entre l'efficacité
et la durée
du parcours des étudiants des étudiants
en plus ce qu'on veut à tout prix garder
donc on a créé la semestrialisation
ensuite on a permis de fusionner ont été
tués qui passe maintenant en deuxième ou
en troisième année alors qu'ils n'ont
pas leur première ou la deuxième année
on leur donne la possibilité
éventuellement rattraper enfin une
espèce de système hyper compliqué à
gérer qui nous fait perdre à nous
enseignants beaucoup de temps et qui
fait que bien de l'universel devient
espèce de parking à un chômeur à la con
con et qu'on évite de mettre sur le
marché du travail donc c'est un
véritable problème on peut constater
aussi le le constat du déclassement de
l'université alors ça a été dit par
patrick est un véritable recul de
l'autonomie des universités moi j'étais
quand même sidéré de voir que le
ministère s'est occupé de définir les
mentions des basses terres nous a dit il
ya trop de mention des mastères les
pauvres enfants se perdent dans les
mentions des mastères donc on va faire
un beau jardin à la française et on va
décider depuis paris les mentions des
mastères absolument aucun sens c'est aux
enseignants dans les universités sur le
terrain avec les professionnels de
définir les mentions d'aidé master pour
la sélection en master c'est pareil
puisque ministère a décidé maintenant
s'occuper la sélection en master et de
décider là on pouvait sélectionner là on
peut pas sélectionner c'est un recul
extrêmement graves de l'autonomie la
concentration si des pouvoirs entre les
mains du président d université des
conseils d'administration a quand même
un sujet qu'il faut qu'on se pose dans
les universités pluridisciplinaires
s'éteint c'est un vrai problème
je voudrais simplement un exemple très
concret je me suis battu pendant trois
ans pour créer un des vcs de droit des
affaires ce que je savais qu'il y avait
un besoin concret pour
les professionnels qui m'entouraient ce
décès s'est aujourd'hui un master il
existe encore douze ans après seulement
l'université avait décidé que
l'environnement était la thématique de
l'université et donc on nous a dit il
faut créer un débat droit de
l'environnement
donc on n'a pas le choix et puis on a
recruté un professeur qu'on a absolument
vous annoncer dans d'autres disciplines
on a recruté un professeur qui nous est
arrivé tout droit voilà en droit de
l'environnement
seulement trois ans après la formation
avait fermé parce qu'il n'y a pas de
débouchés
on savait qu'ils avaient pas débouché
nous en droit de l'environnement mais on
nous a imposé depuis la présence de
l'université cette formation dont je
pense qu'il faut vraiment faire très
attention à ne pas trop concentrées dans
une cité les pouvoirs entre le président
le conseil d'administration patrick tu
as dit c'est dans le document qui est
dans les questions qui vous seront
posées mais je pense qu'il faut
rééquilibrer les choses avec le conseil
scientifique et puis faut aussi accorder
un minimum d'autonomie aux disciplines
dans les universités parce que c'est une
discipline à lauzon travail absolument
pas de la même façon et il faut faire
très attention à ne pas donner aux
incidents du discipline tous les
pouvoirs dans une université surtout
quand elle est pluri disciplinaire alors
les solutions les propositions pourrait
faire d'autres constats je vais en
rester là pour laisser la parole à
d'autres après moi mais c'est l'acte de
l'autonomie ça a été dit par notre
secrétaire national alors ça veut dire
en matière de gouvernance et bien créer
un contrepouvoir au conseil
d'administration et au président à
travers un un conseil scientifique
supprimer la mainmise des syndicats sur
l'université parce que j'ai ainsi il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont
bien aujourd'hui à ma mise des syndicats
d'enseignants et pour certains
d'étudiants dans l'université qui est
absolument dramatique
avec l'unef voyez bâclé leader de l'unef
n'ont qu'une idée c'est de devenir un
jour député socialiste ou ministre et
donc qui profitent de de la moindre
occasion
même contre le proc leur propre
gouvernement pour essayer de jeter les
étudiants dans la rue histoire de passer
sur bfm itélé pour se faire remarquer
des dirigeants du parti face c'est la
triste réalité aujourd'hui du
syndicalisme
étudiant de gauche quant aux syndicats
enseignants de gauche ils sont ils sont
pas mieux et ce sont les plus
conservateurs des conservateurs et on a
vu comment ils ont cherché par exemple
bloquer la réforme de l'autonomie des
universités qui pourtant était
absolument indispensable
il faut évidemment donner une vraie
autonomie aux universités dans le
recrutement dans la rémunération dans
les sources de financement dans
l'autonomie des disciplines dans
l'ouverture de l'université à
l'entreprise incubateurs des campus par
exemple il faut aussi accepter la
sélection c'est un c'est absolument
indispensable
on est malade l'absence de sélection on
sait très bien que voilà on pourrait par
exemple imaginer que les étudiants qui
ont un bac et que mention bien est un
accès direct à l'université mais que
pour les autres liés au moins un test
peut être un sas ces tasses et à
réfléchir et à imaginer pourquoi pas un
module préparatoire à l'université pour
tester les étudiants est là aussi pour
n'être d'accepter que les étudiants qui
sont vraiment motivés intéressés par la
matière est capable ensuite de suivre
des études universitaires
il faut imaginer aussi le rapprochement
entre les écoles et les universités moi
je pense que c'est un vrai drame
français écoles sont trop petites ne
font pas assez de recherches
par contre elles sélectionnent elles
sont libres de fixer leurs droits
d'inscription
les universités ont des professeurs
excellent cher patrick mais le problème
c'est qu'elles ne peuvent pas
sélectionné et que et bien ils n'ont pas
et n'ont pas toujours les moyens qu'on
les grandes écoles et donc il faudrait
quand même réfléchir à fusionner
universités et grandes écoles et
peut-être a imaginé trois blocs
distincts
lydia pas de moi mais je la reprends à
mon compte des collèges professionnelle
bac + 3 très professionnalisant mais
c'est clair le contrat passé que les
étudiants c'est ou trois ans vous entrez
dans la vie professionnelle parce qu'on
sait très bien que les licences pro
qu'on a créés dans les universités elles
sont un espoir pour beaucoup d'étudiants
de d'entrer ensuite en réalité en master
les jeux termine les grands universités
d'exercer proximité qu'il faut préserver
parce que c'est la démocratisation de
l'enseignement supérieur il faut éviter
de massification imbéciles mais par
contre il faut maintenir l'effort de
démocratisation l'enseignement supérieur
et puis des grandes universités à
rayonnement international
bref le chantier est immense l'objectif
sauver d'université le moyen une réforme
radicale et ambitieuse merci merci
beaucoup daniel effectivement cette
proposition des droits blog des trois
blocs on va la reprendre
je cède la parole maintenant sans
transition jean michel nicolle qui est
président de l'union des grandes écoles
indépendantes et directeur d'une école
qui s'appelle le pf
voilà et je me demande vraiment de
respecter cinq minutes parce qu on est
maintenant très près ces jeux merci
bonjour mesdames et messieurs
effectivement j'ai cinq minutes pour
pour faire tomber quelques mythes et
éclairer cet enseignement supérieur
privé qui est souvent soit ostracisé
soit mal connus ou parfois même rejeté
vous verrez tout à l'heure dans quelques
éléments que j'apporterai alors
l'enseignement supérieur en europe c'est
20 millions
deux jeunes c'est deux millions sept
cent mille pour l'enseignement supérieur
privé
une croissance qui était très forte en
europe puisque quand on regarde deux
pays voisins l'allemagne l'autriche
ce sont des chiffres multipliés par huit
en 10 12 ans pour cet enseignement
supérieur privé en france tout à l'heure
patrick évoqué est effectivement donc
les les deux millions quatre étudiants
d'enseignement supérieur 450000 sont
dans le privé avec une croissance de 50%
pour l'enseignement sueur privé depuis
donc une très forte croissance et
aujourd'hui cet enseignement supérieur
c'est 18% des effectifs alors un
enseignement supérieur qui n'est pas
venue en concurrence avec le secteur
public il est venu apporter une offre
nouvelle supplémentaire
et puis il est aussi venu couvrir des
besoins qui n'était pas servi par
l'université où le où l'enseignement
supérieur public
c'est un secteur qui est extrêmement
diversifié on trouve toutes sortes de
deux structures juridiques au sein de ce
secteur
ce sont des établissements et je pense
en particulier donc à ces grandes écoles
bonjour monsieur le président voilà je
pense en particulier à ces grandes
écoles qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure ses grandes écoles école de
commerce école d'ingénieur sont évalués
comme les écoles publiques par la
commission des titres d'ingénieur elles
font l'objet d'une évaluation du hcr est
ce une évaluation donc de l'état elles
sont aujourd'hui pour certaines d'entre
elles établissements d'enseignement
supérieur privés d'intérêt général dont
qu'elles ont aujourd'hui toutes les
toutes les qualités qui permettent de
les identifier à celles qui opèrent dans
le secteur public même cartographie
sociale curieusement et contrairement à
certains préjugés
on retrouve dans ces écoles privées une
cartographie social qui est de même
nature que celle que l'on trouve à
l'université ou dans les grandes écoles
publiques depuis 2010 donc un certain
nombre de ces établissements ont été
contractualisés avec l'état l'objectif
c'était évidemment de créer une
dynamique collective établissements
privés établissement public avec un
certain nombre de promesses
cinquante sept établissements ont été
contractualisés
ces promesses ont été en partie tenu
pendant deux ans puis ensuite ont fondu
rapidement et simplement pour donner
quelques chiffres là je parle d'argent
je suis désolé 21 % du financement de
ces écoles contractualiser a fondu alors
qu'elle s'était engagée à l'époque à
embaucher du personnel à mettre en place
une recherche qui soit tout à fait
emblématique est à la hauteur de ce
qu'on peut attendre d'un établissement
d'enseignement supérieur privé ou public
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que
finalement cette baisse de financement
mais en véritable danger cet
enseignement supérieur
la perte depuis deux ans du droit de
délivrer un diplôme national pour ces
établissements privés la baisse
substantielle des ressources il ya taxe
d'apprentissage qui résulte de la
superbe réforme de cette taxe
d'apprentissage tout ceci finalement
conduit aujourd'hui à une équation qui
devient sur le plan économique tout à
fait insupportable et avec pourtant des
établissements qui accueillent
aujourd'hui 80 mille étudiants c'est à
dire qu'ils font économiser à l'état en
gros 800 millions d'euros
et je pose la question oui des 335
milles jeunes qui vont arriver dans
l'enseignement supérieur dans les dix
ans qui viennent c'est à dire trois
milliards d'euros
il faut que les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur privés jouent
aussi leur rôle et prennent leur place
de façon justement à contribuer à
alléger
donc le coût public de cette formation
et puis je souhaite en conclusion donc
que l'on se sort du face à face public
privé pour qu'on regarde un peu à
l'extérieur et qu'on se rende compte que
la concurrence allait à l'extérieur de
nos frontières elle n'est pas dans notre
dans notre nation et que public privé
doivent travailler ensemble pour faire
en sorte que ce modèle de formation qui
est un modèle d'excellence français
puissent effectivement se diffuser à
l'étranger et puis je voudrais conclure
puisque ont évoqué tout à l'heure jean
baptiste vous évoquez ces établissements
américains qui
r effectivement de la création d'emplois
et bien les neuf sur dix les neuf sur
les dix premiers établissements
américains sont des établissements
privés qui ont exactement les
caractéristiques de lespugue c'est à
dire ces établissements d'enseignement
supérieur privés d'intérêt général donc
ces établissements peuvent prendre leur
place et aujourd'hui donc un rôle
important à jouer avec les
établissements secondaires publics
merci merci beaucoup jean-michel on est
tout à fait convaincu de sa est ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que si on
coupe les vivres de l'enseignement
supérieur privé en fait ça nous coûtera
plus cher
au bout du compte et ça nous fait une
transition toute trouvée avec
l'intervenant suivant qui est qui et
laurent bigorgne le directeur d'un
institut montaigne inquiets l'institut
montaigne qui a qui a produit un rapport
très important et dont on s'est beaucoup
inspiré je veux le dire
las de l'année dernière sur
l'enseignement supérieur a dirigé par
jean marc stein stein coeur et
laurent tu vas nous parlait ce matin du
la question cruciale du financement de
l'enseignement supérieur on va faire
très vite merci beaucoup jean baptiste
vous avez dit tout c'est très très
patient et puis je crois que vous
attendez une prise de parole important
donc je vais essayer d'être très très
rapide
moi j'ai deux conseils au fond au moment
où votre famille politique je regarde de
l'extérieur et en même temps avec
beaucoup d'affection au moins votre
famille politique s'apprête à faire un
travail intellectuel politique
s'agissant de l'éducation et
d'universités la première chose de vous
rappeler qu'il a fallu un certain
courage pour faire un autonomie des
universités particulièrement à vous qui
vivier au fond des traumatismes 68 86 et
que ce n'était pas au fond très intuitif
d'ailleurs en premier sur ces questions
au moment où vous arriviez aux
responsabilités en 2007 il a fallu du
courage et ce courage
j'allais dire qu'il va vous falloir
aujourd'hui parce qu'il était en 2007
appuyez sur une réflexion dans le
rapport camdessus qui avait été demandé
par nos ministres d'économie de l'époque
en 2004 il y avait toute une réflexion
sur l'autonomie c'est une réflexion qui
venaient de loin je suis convaincu qu on
fait des réformes a publié le monsieur
le député à des réformes radicales de
l'enseignement supérieur quand on y
pense quand on sait qu'il ya vision
qu'on veut porter votre famille a aussi
ses conservatismes
je vais vous dire comme je vous vois
elle à son envie de réformes et là aussi
c'est conservatisme quand on parle
d'université elle a aussi ses blocages
elle a aussi ses jacobinisme et si vous
ne vous mettez pas d'accord si vous
n'avez pas de courage d'aller au fond de
ces débats bien sûr vous appellerai tous
de vos voeux autonomie personne n'y
mettra le même sens et au final les
français seront peau mais ne vous
suivront pas donc je veux bien qu'on
fasse effectivement un acte de
l'autonomie moi j'appellerai ça
personnellement la vraie autonomie
il fallait du courage en en 2007 il en
faudra encore plus dix ans après mais
attention en discuter au fond des
problèmes aller au fond des messages
pour être sûr que des non dits ne
viendront pas le moment venu perturber
le dessin politique qui est le vôtre ça
c'était mon premier conseil si je puis
me permettre de vous adresser ainsi
encore une fois en toute amitié
mon deuxième conseil c'est sûr en font
le fait qu'il est toujours plus agréable
d'être de l'autre côté de la rivière
qu'au milieu du gué et donc quand on
fait d'autonomie
il faut des marqueurs pour montrer qu'au
final la situation irréversible
je vais prendre un exemple on est
suffisamment en amitié avec patrick pour
que je le dise mais je vous ai entendu
aussi sur ce que vous avez du ministère
mais quand on fait autonomie ministères
tels qu'ils existaient avant autonomie
ne peut pas être que ministères tels
qu'ils existent après autonomie et donc
moi j'ai envie de vous dire si vous
voulez faire un vrai autonomie il ya
plus de ministère il ya peut-être même
plus de mise ah bah oui je vous vois me
dire tout de suite on n'est pas sûr mais
d'autonomie c'est ça si je suis autonome
j'ai plus tutelle évidemment que le
ministère notre premier objectif qu'il a
dès que vous avez le dos tourné
c'est reprendre tout pouvoir que vous
gaver piqué ça paraît assez naturel
c'est de la sociologie administratives
pour le coup d'étudiants de première
année les professeurs donc je pense que
si vous voulez faire autonomie il ya un
moment ou un autre il faut faire comme
les anglais il ya un secrétaire d'état
qui s'occupe de l'enseignement supérieur
d'un point de vue stratégique yves
auprès du ministre de l'économie parce
que vous avez raison l'enseignement
supérieur c'est un programme de
croissance et de compétitivité
et puis il ya des agences de financement
et d'évaluation s'agencent elles sont
indépendantes elles sont rigoureuses
elles sont sérieuses elles font peur
elles font peur à tous les présidents
d'université à leur équipe quand elle
passe et l'autonomie c'est ça c'est à la
fois j'ai droit à ma nation m'octroie
des moyens de travail et puis j'ai des
devoirs et d'un dernier mot sur le
financement avait sur la question des
droits de scolarité un système gratuit
d'enseignement supérieur est un système
inégalitaire parce que c'est un système
d'insider accède aux meilleures places
dans l'enseignement supérieur
ce au fond qui viennent des familles qui
ont eu plus d'informations qui ont plus
de capital social qui regroupe plus de
capitale culturelle
donc au final et je rends un hommage à
la mémoire de richard descoings auprès
duquel j'ai eu la chance de travailler
il avait compris vu juste plus de
l'enseignement supérieur et gratuit plus
il est inégalitaire
parce que accéderont à la ressource rare
c'est à dire aux meilleures places de
l'enseignement supérieur ceux qui auront
le plus de capital social
turenne économique à d'origine pour
arriver à ces plats signés monopoly zig
& trust de centre aujourd'hui dans les
grandes écoles mais aussi dans les airs
de l'université dans le m2 les plus
sélectifs on cultive un d'entre eux soit
qui est délétère pour l'avenir du pays
donc il faut monter en puissance sur la
question des droits de scolarité et il
faut faire avec des caves est apte
j'en ai terminé il faut que faire en
ayant en tête ni quitter ce qu'il faudra
le faire dans les grandes écoles aussi
je pas sûr qu'il soit encore d'une
certaine logique qu'on finance les
études des normaliens aujourd'hui il
faut avoir un moment ou un autre
la capacité dire ces choses d'ouvrir
cdma mais s'il faut aller au bout tu
pourquoi avoir des tabous il faut aller
au bout de ces questions il faut aller
au bout de ces questions ne s'embrouille
tigres je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
faire autonomy demain qu'on puisse faire
le financement par les droits de
scolarité sans donner des assurances sur
l'engagement de l'état pour une cuisse
est un libéral qui vous dit il faut
s'occuper aussi de l'augmentation de la
qualité des services
il faut aussi s'occuper effectivement de
la différenciation des prix n'est pas
normal qu'un master soit payée
évidemment comme une licence est pas
normal qu un master en finance coûte le
même prix qu'un master en anthropologie
donc il faudra accepter de voir ces
choses j'allais dire par le bas il
faudra laisser ça entre les mains des
universités c'est qu'ils ne voudront pas
faire des droits de scolarité vers se
retrouveront avec moins de moyens que
celles qui auront courage de les faire
et je crois qu'il faut avoir le courage
de dire aux acteurs demain que ce
problème qui est en même temps une
solution au problème de financement est
un problème qui concerne au premier chef
mais encore une fois vous avez encore le
temps de vous mettre au clair sur ces
questions elles ne sont pas simples il
faut en avoir conscience
elles font naître des réticences mais je
crois que les français attendent de vous
vous y ait un discours très clair sur
ces questions qui sont évidemment très
puissante quand à l'avenir de leurs
enfants et de même merci
merci beaucoup laurent avec ta
proposition de supprimer le ministre
d'enseignement supérieur est en train de
tuer des espérances dans cette salle
enfin on va on va y réfléchir je laisse
la parole pour une minute olivier vial
qui est le président d'une organisation
syndicale qui n'ont pas syndicale
étudiante qui est universel aliments qui
est plus constructive que celle dont
parle et daniel fasquelle tout à l'heure
oui juste pour effectivement du coup on
est un petit peu une expérience depuis
quelques années sur le l'université
c'est que on voit effectivement quand on
est à l'intérieur de l'université qui a
une nécessité de réformes importantes ce
qui est ce qui empêche l'opinion de se
mobiliser c'est que il ya un voile
d'hypocrisie sur pas mal de questions
qui fait qu'on a l'impression tout va
bien de l'extérieur et que aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs le discours de du ministre
actuel c'est de dire finalement punir si
c'est l'endroit où il ya des problèmes
peut-être dans l'éducation dans le sud
dans secondaire mais dans le supérieur
ça va à peu près je voudrais m'élever 3
hypocrisie la première hypocrisie c'est
cette idée reçue l'université française
est ouverte à tous puisqu'en fait il ya
effectivement de sélection on en a tous
parlé c'est une sélection par l'échec
elle est très forte on la vit c'est
moins de moins de 4 étudiants sur 10 qui
réussissent leur licence en trois ans
toutes filières confondues tous bacs
confondus pour les bacs pros on en a
parlé des taux d'échec important
mes gars très concrètement l'université
d'amiens a évalué endroit le nombre de
bacheliers pros ils en ont chaque année
une plus d'une dizaine et ça augmente
puisque il faut savoir que 20 %
d'étudiants de bacheliers pros de plus
dans l'université que qu'il ya qu'en
ça augmente régulièrement et bien en
cinq ans sur les dizaines de bacheliers
pros qui sont inscrits en droit le taux
de réussite il est simple il est de 0%
il n'y a pas eu un seul bacheliers pros
qui a réussi à passer en deuxième année
on ment aux étudiants ce mensonge là il
leur coûte cher à eux et coûte cher à
leurs familles il coûte cher à l'état
si on additionne le coût des mauvaises
orientations il faut alors qu'en gros
aujourd'hui à l'université il ya un
tiers un gros tiers qui réussit sa liste
qu'il réussit sa licence un autre tiers
qui va soit avoir une erreur
d'orientation se réorienter ou
abandonner ses études et un petit et est
à peu près un autre tiers qui va
redoubler on a dans ce cadre là cet
échec scolaire plus l'échec
l'orientation s'écoute 2 milliards
d'euros par an 2 milliards d'euros par
an ça veut dire que le budget de
l'enseignement supérieur il ya presque
il ya plus de 13 % de ce budget là qui
part pour finalement une des des sortes
de marge d'erreur quoi tout ce qui ne
fonctionne pas ça coûte 2 milliards
d'euros juste sur les entrants est ce
qu'on peut avoir un système est ce qu'on
tolérerait dans un autre une autre
institution où il ya une marge d'erreur
aussi importante où ça coûte aussi cher
aux familles et à l'état donc ça c'est
de la première chose c'est que ça coûte
très cher que dans le même temps parce
qu'on a eu cette hypocrisie de penser
que tout le monde pouvait rentrer et
qu'il suffisait de mettre plus de moyens
sur le tutorat etc
on a mis beaucoup d'argent sur le plan
réussite en licence le bilan c'est que
ça ne marche pas parce que la première
des choses c'est quand même de
sélectionner les bonnes personnes selon
leurs aptitudes pour réussir les
universités quand on met simplement des
rustines eh ben on a encore aujourd'hui
malgré les plans de réussite en licence
malgré tout ce qui a été fait sur le
tutorat sur l'accompagnement le taux de
réussite en licence
il continue à diminuer et on s'enfonce
de plus en plus donc ça c'est la
première chose c'est que clairement oui
il ya besoin de mettre d'une vraie
sélection de section qui soient assumées
basée sur le mérite sur les aptitudes et
pas une sélection sur les chèques qui
décourage beaucoup d étudiants et qui
nous coûtent très cher donc je crois
qu'effectivement si les établissements
pourraient avoir la liberté de fixer les
modalités de sélection ça serait un vrai
plus dans l'autonomie deuxième devient
l'altitude patrick en a un petit peu
parlé c'est l'insertion professionnelle
on dit partout vous inquiétez pas le
diplôme c'est un rempart pour leur
emploi contre le chômage c'est à la fois
très vrai est à la fois il ya des vraies
difficultés puisque là encore hypocrisie
totale vous regardez les chiffres qui
sont publiés par les universités elles
vous donnent des côtes de la station
provinciale de leurs étudiants entre 97%
et 99 % de réussite alors ils prennent
que certains master et c'est très
comique c'est vraiment des cif qui
centrait pour faire de la communication
mais c'est les chiffres officiels c'est
ici que vous retrouver partout alors
y'a pas de problème vous voyez ça
protège malheureusement l'apec donne pas
du tout les mêmes chiffres
quarante deux pour cent des étudiants de
master ne trouvent pas d'emploi dans
l'année qui suit leur sortie de diplômes
42% de bac + 5
donc on a une différence et ça ce qui
est scandaleux c'est que cette
différence elles sont aussi flagrante
entre les chiffres de l'apec et ceux
affichés par les universités parce qu'on
voit qu'il une forme de déni de réalité
donc il ya un vrai problème et ce
problème de l'emploi et de l'insertion
professionnelle eh ben on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement il s'est aggravée
puisque avec la crise les diplômés qui
sont passés de verser son passé bien
préparé donc subissent plus la crise que
les diplômés d'écoles que certains
diplômes c'est presque un peu plus
d'études qu'on réussit mieux la preuve
c'est que les les doctorants ont des
niveaux d'insertion bruxelles qui sont
plus faibles que certains bac +5 avec
des salaires d'embauché qui sont
quelquefois inférieur donc là aussi ça
donne une très mauvaise image de la
science puisqu'on s'aperçoit que plus on
fait des études
c'est pas un gage forcément de réussite
et puis on va le dernier la dernière 1
pour aller très vite
la dernière thématique où on a beaucoup
menti c'est en gros lumière ces
françaises seraient l'université la plus
sociale avec un système d'être social
qui serait parfait alors c'est
exactement le contraire
effectivement on a décidé de faire un
système totalement tout social reposant
sur un acteur quasiment unique qu'est le
crous et ce système là à plusieurs
caractéristiques un seul système qui est
le moins d'étudiants de toute l'europe
on a à peu près on a moins de 30% des
clients et des alors que dans les pays
ultra libéraux comme l'angleterre ou les
états unis on entre 75 et 85 %
on a un système où le l'offre de
logements ne concerne l'aide pour les
gens ne consomment que 7% des étudiants
on a un système où l'aide aux repas
l'aide elle est d'aider récent
anniversaire ne concerne que 4 % des
repas qui sont fournis donc on a un
système qui exclut totalement les
classes moyennes qui exclut mérite
puisque les bourses au mérite ont été
rabotées pour les bacheliers l on était
dans le plus haut en séance totalement
supprimée à l'université et on a un
système
on la choisit de logiquement parce que
on pouvait préférer les bourses au
mérite
on pouvait les finances et ne serait-ce
que en ayant une vraie reconnaissance de
l'assiduité
aujourd'hui le ministère et les
universités n'ont pas souhaité faire le
choix de donner des bourses à ceux qui
le méritent et à ceux qui travaillent
puisque par exemple on a refusé de se
retirer les bourses aux étudiants qui ne
sont pas assidus en cours ça existe dans
les textes mais ce n'est pas appliquée
ça représente à peu près 100 millions
d'euros et ce n'est pas et ça n'a pas
été fait et on a fait ce choix
idéologique de préville d'accise pour
éviter justement la colère de certains
syndicats étudiants plutôt que de faire
en sorte de mettre l'argent là où on en
avait besoin
c'est à dire pour donner de l'argent aux
étudiants des classes moyennes pour les
aider à financer leurs études puisque ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qui est un
tabou qui n'est pas dit c'est que ce
sont les classes moyennes qui ont le
plus compté le plus pénalisé par la
crise et qu'aujourd'hui la seule
catégorie qui désertent les études
supérieures et qui est de moins en moins
nombreux chez les étudiants issus des
classes moyennes c'est eux qui depuis
conques de façon continue voix pour deux
raisons un soin qui désertent les
formations universitaires soit parce
qu'ils désertent totalement les
formations d'enseignement supérieur et
là effectivement il ya une vraie
difficulté aujourd'hui donc je crois que
si on veut pouvoir réformer
il faut donner plus de liberté mais il
faut le faire surtout regarder la
réalité en face
parce qu'il ya un vrai déni de réalité
est que quand on voit ce qui se passe
dans les lignes arrières quand on voit
l'argent qui est part en fumée avec ses
erreurs d'orientation ses erreurs de qui
est qui ont été faits dans le système on
a effectivement une un sentiment de
gâchis humain et financier qui est
insupportable
au mans on aurait effectivement besoin
l'université qu'ils soient locaux
motivent pour notre pays donc je crois
qu'il ya un vrai sujet en tout cas les
étudiants ils sont prêts c'est tabou là
c'est plus est à bout d'un forme
d'institution puisque par exemple sur
l'île pour rien sur la sélection sur la
sélection plus de 7 étudiants 7 75% des
étudiants et des bacheliers fonds en
premier choix le choix d'une filière
sélective
ils veulent tous rentrés dans les
filières celles qui veulent tous ces
filières sélectives et parce que on
n'est pas capable de leur proposer une
offre sélective qu'ils soient de qualité
à la hauteur de leur demande que
malheureusement il ya cette sélection
par l'échec
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette table ronde est donc sans
transition je laisse la parole à notre
président nicolas sarkozy